you probably remember north carolina's
hb2 bill part of that bill requires that
individuals use the bathroom associated
with their birth genitalia also may be
less publicized but that bill hb2 in
north carolina it banned
anti-discrimination protections for LGBT
individuals it basically said
municipalities within North Carolina
can't pass their own ordinances
protecting against discrimination of
LGBT individuals tons of blowback loss
of business a terrible PR a lot of
events canceling their plans to go to
North Carolina and that makes sense
because it's a totally absurd bill well
the North Carolina legislature plans to
convene a special session today to talk
about repealing that bill the
governor-elect Democrat Roy Cooper said
yesterday that Republican leaders
assured him yes we are going to meet to
talk about repealing this bill and I
know that this all sounds great and
obviously repealing the bill is good but
this is the epitome of backroom politics
here's what happened the Charlotte City
Council unanimously voted yesterday in
the morning to rescind its ordinance
protecting LGBT people and that was the
catalyst for the Republican legislature
passing HB 2 in the first place so the
the basically the backroom deal that was
struck was okay we passed HB to banning
anti-discrimination ordinances at the
municipality level because Charlotte
passed an ordinance banning
discrimination at the municipality level
so Charlotte rescinds their bill and
Republicans will get together and look
at rescinding HB 2 the current
Republican Governor Pat McCrory's office
also confirmed that they would call the
legislature into a special session so
here's their statement now that the
Charlotte ordinance has been repealed
the expectation of privacy in our
showers bathrooms and locker rooms is
restored and protected under previous
state law governor McCrory has always
publicly advocated a repeal of the
overreaching Charlotte ordinance but
those
firts were always blocked by Jennifer
Roberts Roy Cooper and other Democratic
activists there is a lot of political BS
going on here when Charlotte retracts
their law a lot of hb2 is no longer
necessary and you can still discriminate
the real question is what happens after
governor elect Cooper is sworn in
because there's speculation Pat that as
soon as this is all done and Cooper is
sworn in that he will then push for
statewide protection based on sexual
orientation and gender identity yeah it
seems like this is just a made-up excuse
I mean this bill HB 2 did a lot of
negative things for the state for the
businesses there and of course for the
transgender community as if they care
about that and you know bad reputation
for the state of course they're going to
try to repeal it not only that this is
also blamed this ridiculous abortive law
called HB 2 is blamed Pat McCrory the
Republican governor did not lose by much
in that North Carolina gubernatorial
election and there are absolutely
moderate Republicans who opted not to
vote for Pat McCrory not necessarily
voting for his opponent but maybe just
not voting at all and you can make a
very strong case that HB 2 alone is
responsible for Pat McCrory losing
re-election there now what ultimately
happens is really important here
obviously but regardless of what happens
this entire thing is the worst of the
worst of gutter politics the using
people's ability to live free of
discrimination as a political move on
the proverbial chessboard
and as Pat mentioned financially it's
been terrible and this is the type of
politics that is the worst of American
politics I obviously hope with regard to
the law that it's repealed and that then
Roy Cooper sticks it to them by passing
a full protection statewide of sexual
identity and gender gender and sexual
orientation protection but this is just
horrible politics at its absolute worst
thanks for watching this video before
you watch the next one remember we're
raising money to expand the David Pakman
show big league as well as expand
progressive activism go to david
pakman.com slash donate donations of any
size are much appreciated